this is probably the biggest era of
change coming up since the invention of
the iPhone accelerated social media in a
profound way if that will be some of the
biggest opportunities that you will ever
see in your entire life when faced with
somebody telling you something you've
never heard about before or something
new in your journey if you meet that new
genre that new platform that new
technology with the concept of maybe
you will have a much greater chance to
get out of the world what you want
purebred entrepreneur for real for real
for real like documented
[Music]
we should run away
so we manage all of the Middle East
turkey African South Asia from Dubai yep
so you've got about 500 people overall
managing this part of the world and yeah
they're all excited to uh to hear from
glad to be here ladies and gentlemen
all right welcome Gary thank you
Innovation and what separates the real
Innovations
these AI products that are out there
right now forget them out we have to
figure out copyright and trademark I
mean we can't even begin to use the
creative products at our agency because
we don't know the sources of the
creative and we have contracts with our
clients that put us in a vulnerable spot
but entrepreneurs and small businesses
they'll do it all day long the critical
thinking of the input becomes a really
interesting game you know it's really
funny for me to watch all these schools
and universities ban all these products
they'd rather have kids memorize
information that's a commodity then
start teaching people critical thinking
of inputting into the AI products which
is actually the punch line this is what
I've been waiting for my whole life I've
never been good at the commodity I can't
put seven sentences together that are
proper grammar but I can come up with
the ideas I'm actually very excited I've
heard a lot of people talk about this is
bad for the creative industry like this
is the greatest thing that's ever
happened in the creative industry it's
just going to be the greatest thing that
happens to the creative people the
commodity of Korea activity executing it
that's going to be commoditized but
that's what's always happened
innovation's always going to do this so
I think the interesting thing is twofold
one this is about to expose the most
creative critical thinkers and two it's
still going to come down to the idea
anytime you have your heart and your
brain 100 aligned on something please
stop hesitating because the only thing
that's stopping you is your insecurity
at that point your anxiety and
insecurity in your body is always wrong
and yet a lot of you allow it to make
decisions above your heart and your head
and it is the great mistake of the human
being we talked about a lot of stuff
today but if you leave with anything
when your heart and your head agree it's
always right
[Music]
I look as always awesome thank you I
enjoyed it I did a great job thank you
there's not a single creative agency
that of the like the great 30 40 which I
have incredible admiration for what they
do making a television commercial the
problem is if they ever took those
talents and refurbished them to
understand how to make day in and day
out creative work in Social
the talents that all these creative
agencies would have a much better life
they would enjoy it could you imagine
being someone who's creative sitting in
nine months of meetings and then a year
later like seven months later seeing a
television commercial and seeing a speck
of what you thought in it 16 months to
get to get to something that doesn't see
the letter day and ends up on The
Cutting Room floor I wonder what they
saw of what you said that we at the
agency are our goal is to create 40 to
70 pieces of content a day they don't
hear that ever in the region ever Gary
ever they don't hear it in America
nobody's made that commitment yet except
for small businesses and creators
entrepreneurs small businesses The
Fortune 500
landscape is only hearing that for the
first time by us and it's working
friends
we're in Dubai
come say hello if you're in the region
right Mana okay let's try this I wish I
had eyes in the back of my head I've
been working on my private Direction
he's the CEO of be friends and
vaynermedia and the chairman of Vayner
acts today we have Gary V with us hi
Carrie how are you I'm good what is the
ratio that someone needs to have between
empathy and decisiveness well I think
for me empathy leads to my decisiveness
if you can actually feel the other
person and take in their feelings
whether it's one person or the world or
a Target you're going after really
leaning on curiosity and empathy leads
to decisiveness and so I don't view them
as counters I view that one is feeding
the other you have a knack for
predicting consumer Trends and behaviors
can you give us a read on what's gonna
what's about to happen in on social
media platforms and media in general
because I know that you were a big
advocator for nfts and everything so
tell us a little bit about how you see
things going so first of all I don't
think I tend to predict I think I talk
about what things are happening so for
example last year billions of dollars
were spent on nfts on a weekly basis
this is happening pay attention but to
your point nine months later I started
making unlimited videos that say 99 of
these nfts are going to go to zero
because I was observing the behavior and
everybody was just looking for a get
rich quick or a quick trade and so
that's bad behavior so that was obvious
right now we're looking at AI it's very
easy everyone's getting captivated by AI
chat EBT Jasper this and what's
happening we are demonizing it because
we're scared of this big new technology
yet it's going to be one of the greatest
impacts on our society thank you so much
cheers
[Music]
what do you see the next big thing
I believe in nfts tremendously it was
really just the way I saw it last year
like if 99 aren't good then 99 won't be
valuable 99 of social media accounts
don't get big doesn't mean social media
is not right yeah so it's it's less
about it to me the next big thing is
executing on the current things
we're also living at a time where
everyone is looking for scale and
automation which means fail but not debt
the amount of people that are actually
committing to building meaningful
relationships with their customers is
almost non-existent in the hyperbole of
innovation so what's interesting to me
is
the last 20 years
it seemingly looked like the people that
had the advantages were the ones that
invested in Automation and scale and
technology and that's what we saw happen
what's happening now is because the cat
is out of the bag and everybody
understands that that starts to over
time become the commodity and the
advantage becomes the things that are
not automated that are not Technology
based they're human based this will be
accelerated dramatically with AI soon
everybody's white paper or presentations
are going to look the same because
they're all going to use the same
technology but the inputs from the human
level become the variable
lucky that I'm innocent uh
uh did you have a moment in your life in
your career where you found your voice
how did you discover it and how did you
know how to use it I knew how to use it
because all I'm really trying to do for
the world is what my mom did for me
which is create a level of accountable
practical optimism and joy and love not
the expense of Merit so it was easy for
me to figure out what I wanted to do
with my voice as far as how I created it
or structured it or more importantly
protected it one of the things that's
really interesting about me in hindsight
is how little I listen to other voices I
think one of the ways I found my voice
was by really owning my voice because I
wasn't spending time listening to other
voices my voice has been developed in
the trenches of interacting with lots of
people and so I I argue that a lot of
people listening or watching should
spend more time listening to lots of
humans listening to themselves and so
I'm very proud of how I developed my
voice that came out of a deeply
empathetic and deeply sympathetic and
deeply
motivated for value for others place and
I think that's why it's resonating thank
you thank you so much just out here on
the beach with my fingers in the sand
and the water at my feet can I just get
some release Here everybody falls off
the tipia one year just following your
advice yes it's working content pumping
content and playing the game yes I
wanted your advice but take it to the
next level up we want to hire what was
your your advice make sure you realize
what you guys like to do what you're
good at right you sit down piece of
paper what do you like to do yeah and
what are you good at and then the other
side what don't you like to do or what
you're not good at as soon as you have
that side you hire as much for that as
possible thank you brother
congratulations
my mom's new house this is me
investigation but there's better coming
out I came out when I was 18 and my mom
kicked me out now I'm sitting in the
kitchen in a brand new house man it's
funny how it all pan out almost like the
man upstairs got it all planned out and
I know if I believe that but I know
right now if it's my moment I'm a season
it won't All Fall Down
my sneakers here you can take them try
my love if you want been a hard thing to
find something
foreign
when I thought about building my dad's
liquor store in the mid 90s I ran
newspaper ads and did radio and did
direct mail in the late 90s very quickly
I realized the internet was here and
that became email marketing and Google
AdWords the way I think everyone in here
needs to navigate social media is well
if you're a B2B company in here and
you're not posting three or four times a
day on LinkedIn to extract value of
awareness and lead generation and
consideration and brand building then
you're leaving opportunity on the table
when the cost of awareness is almost
zero anybody who's capable of doing
anything at a better cost should do that
thank you very much cheers thank you
[Music]
foreign